TIME, DANNY GREEN A LITTLE LATE
TO THE PARTY.
>> Brian: PHILADELPHIA BY EIGHT.
EMBIID HAS GOT 11 THIS QUARTER.
EMBIID JUST BULLIES HIS WAY IN.
THAT IS GOING TO BE AN OFFENSIVE
FOUL.
EMBIID NOW HIT WITH A "T."
I DON'T KNOW IF THAT WAS THE
EJECTION SIGN OR NOT.
I THINK SCOTT FOSTER JUST HIT
EMBIID WITH A "T."
BOY, HE CAME AT DANILO
GALLINARI.
>> Jim: WATCH THE PLAY.
FIRST THE OFFENSIVE FOUL RIGHT
HERE.
OKAY?
AND THEN AFTERWARD, EMBIID BUMPS
INTO GALLINARI.
GALLINARI WALKS AWAY AND THERE
IS THE PUSH.
GALLINARI INITIATED THAT CONTACT
AND I'M SURE THEY ARE GOING TO
LOOK AT IT.
>> Brian: WE WILL REVIEW THE
ALTERCATION.
>> Jim: EMBIID HAS TO BE SMARTER
IN THAT SITUATION.
GALLINARI KICKED OUT IS ONE
THING.
EMBIID, YOU GETTING KICKED OUT
IS A WHOLE DIFFERENT STORY.
>> Brian: JUST WATCHING THAT
AGAIN.
SCOTT FOSTER WAS EMPHATIC IN HIS
POINT.
BUT I THINK HE WAS JUST POINTING
AT EMBIID, NOT THE TOSS SIGNAL.
WE ARE SITTING UP TOP HERE AT
WELLS FARGO CENTER.
THE WAY EMBIID JUST LEFT THE
FLOOR GOING TO HIS REGULAR SEAT.
>> Jim: YOU WANT THE BEST
PLAYERS IN THE GAME AND THAT
INCLUDES GALLINARI AS WELL TOO
BECAUSE OF THE SHOW HE IS
PUTTING ON NOW IN THIS FIRST
HALF.
YOU WANT HIM TO BE ON THE COURT
IF YOU'RE THE HAWKS.
YOU DON'T WANT ANYTHING THAT
COULD TAKE HIM OUT OF THE GAME.
EMBIID IS LUCKY HE DIDN'T GET A
SECOND ONE ESPECIALLY WITH SCOTT
FOSTER.
I UNDERSTAND THAT SCOTT KNEW THE
TEMPERAMENT OF THESE PLAYERS IN
THE PLAYOFFS AND WOULD NOT BE
THAT QUICK TO THE WHISTLE TO
CALL A BACK-TO-BACK TECHNICAL
FOUL.
>> Brian: REGULAR SEASON THAT IS
PROBABLY AUTOMATIC RIGHT THERE.
>> Jim: EXACTLY, EXACTLY.
>> Brian: TRY TO CALM THINGS
DOWN.
THESE THREE OFFICIALS DO CALM
THEM DOWN.
EMBIID AND GALLINARI GOING AT IT
GOING BACK A COUPLE OF
POSSESSIONS.
THAT WAS ON THAT THREE-POINTER
BY CURRY WHEN THOSE TWO HIT THE
GROUND.
PHYSICAL BASKETBALL.
>> Jim: I LIKE PHYSICAL
BASKETBALL WHEN YOU MAINTAIN
YOUR DISCIPLINE.
>> Brian: EMBIID WILL SIT DOWN.
POTENTIALLY A DOUBLE TECHNICAL
HERE.
LET'S LISTEN IN.
SCOTT FOSTER, THE CREW CHIEF.
>> Referee: --
>> Brian: HE IS EXPLAINING TO
NATE McMILLAN NOW AS THEY HEAT
UP THAT RIGHT KNEE.
>> Brian: DOUBLE TECHNICAL FOUL
HAS BEEN ASSESSED TO GALLINARI
AND DEAD BALL CONTACT.
AND DEAD BALL CONTACT TO EMBIID.
SIDE-OUT.
>> Jim: DEAD BALL CONTACT
MEANING IT WAS THE KIND OF THE
SHOULDER FROM GALLINARI WHEN HE
GOT UP INTO THE CHEST OF EMBIID
AND THEN EMBIID WITH THE
RESPONSE AND THE PUSH.
THAT'S WHY IT'S A DEAD BALL
DOUBLE TECHNICAL FOUL.
>> Brian: JUST MARK THOSE.
IT MATTERS LATER IF THERE ARE
T's ASSESS TO THESE INDIVIDUALS,
IT WOULD BE AN A